hi i'm alex i'm ria and today we're
going to compete to see who can make the
best lunchtime recipe in 30 minutes or
less who do you think is going to win i
think i'm going to win i think you're
going to win too believe in yourself
alex you're right
well we've got 30 minutes so
yeah let's start the timer yes go
[Music]
oh i'm gonna just walk
okay i think i'm gonna make a pasta
salad but i've also done a lot of
cooking challenges and i know that 30
minutes goes by in a flash i'm making
avocado toast i've made avocado toast
thousands of times so i have extra time
to make it a little bit more fancy so
there is an old folktale tortoise and
hair and a total steak time but he wins
so that's my strategy
it's organized it's holidays
you're so neat
[Music]
what just happened they see the wall of
tuna we just got tuned
did you know this is gonna happen
no
okay so surprise twist the real
challenge today is that you have to
incorporate bumblebee albacore tuna into
your lunchtime recipes
first i wasn't sure what i was going to
do with the tuna but then i remembered
i'm making pasta salad and tuna
literally goes perfect in pasta salad
so i'm going to start by boiling my
pasta since it's going to take a while
so i'm going to start with my jammy eggs
because it takes the most time from my
recipe okay now i'm going to prep some
of the ingredients going inside the
pasta salad these are kalamata olives
and now i have some grape tomatoes that
i'm gonna
chop up doesn't have to be perfect
that's the beauty of pasta salad you
really just kind of toss it all together
you're real confident over there taking
your sweet time
[Music]
i'm gonna be making a
dilly dijon vinaigrette for this pasta
salad i love
things that are really herby
i like to use red onion because it's a
little bit milder
so it doesn't overpower tuna or
avocado i'm gonna squeeze some lemon
so avocado doesn't tone brown
how do you feel really good
oh that makes one of us
so now i'm just slicing up some shallots
for my dilly dijon dressing
don't have time to spill right now i've
got some sugar going in for of course a
little sweetness a little salt
and some oil deep breath
i'm good i'm good it's just pasta salad
tuna time
i'm going to open this pouch
oh it's so easy to open
so albacore tuna is a mild flavor so it
can handle strong ingredients like
onions and radish so now i'm just gonna
put some of our pasta in here
and now hit it with all our fun stuff
riya is something burning
my toast
my toast burned and i'm losing my time i
have to cut my bread i have to toast
again so i'm a little bit nervous now
it's boring oh no
okay now we saved the best for last the
tuna of course i need to get this in
there because i'm running out of time oh
look at those big firm pieces of
beautiful white albacore tuna i wanted
the bigger firmer pieces so that they
don't get lost in the pasta salad i'm
going to add all the vegetable i chopped
earlier some greek yogurt
grated garlic and salt
so i'm just gonna mix this together and
we're pretty much done
just the rest of our dressing i'm gonna
pop in
my tuna avocado salad
i'm gonna put a little bit red chili
pepper so it's kind of nice kick to it
three
[Music]
[Laughter]
hi i'm tracy rates i'm a tasty producer
and today i'm going to judge alex and
riya's tuna lunchtime recipes so today
i'm going to be judging alex and riya on
three different categories that is the
presentation which is how it looks
obviously the craveability which is if
i'm going to crave it if i'm going to
want to eat it again and then the
versatility which is how creative they
were with the way they use the tuna i
know tracy so well and i know what she
likes so i'm confident that she's going
to choose me i know we're better than
reid does and i think
i've got this one
hi guys
welcome thank you i'm so excited to try
everything yes really what do you have
for me i have tuna avocado tatting
i have salvador toast and avocado
albacore tuna salad and on the topping i
have radish and tomato and jamie
it looks delicious presentation perfect
i can't wait to dive in so here i go i
gotta get the perfect bite with a little
bit of everything
a little crunch
super super delicious thank you
really good textures overall
i love avocado tuna because it's like
mild so you kind of taste all those
herbs and lemony stuff throughout and it
doesn't really overpower it versatility
wise it is still avocado toast and it's
not super portable but it is super
delicious and i would definitely eat it
again but i'm excited to check out what
alex made i have for you a nicoise pasta
salad it's like a play on a nisswa salad
so usually anisoia salad has potatoes in
it but i'm using pasta for the starch
instead we've got some radish tomatoes
green beans a jammy egg dill and of
course our albacore tuna presentation
wise you're competing with rie who
created the most beautiful toast but i'm
excited to dig in
it's really good
i love the dressing
i definitely taste like dijon
that little horseradish in there super
super flavorful and i love that the
albacore is so mild so it takes on the
dressing but still has a delicious
flavor itself so i love this because i
feel like i'm always eating on the go
and this is super easy to pack up and
take with me yeah so it's very versatile
you can also like change up the veggies
change up the dressing a little bit i've
tried both delicious
but
i mean this is so beautiful you know
like this was just really pretty
and that's why i'm going to have to say
alex is a winner alex is a winner
[Applause]
congratulations
i was going to win
tracy faked me out i thought she was for
sure gonna pick riya's dish i was
stunned when she came back and told me i
was the winner pleasantly surprised
when i tasted the nicoise pasta salad it
was really light and fresh and flavorful
and just a really mouth-watering
delicious lunch that i am going to want
to eat again so that's why it had to be
the winner for me throughout this
competition i was confident i was saying
i'm the tortoise of this competition and
i was gonna win but this time
[Music]
told us
lost
now i'm gonna eat this one yeah i'm
gonna keep eating this one